well hello there dear friends I've got
another poy trick that I want you to
check out take a look at this this is
the PO 3B weave it is probably the
single most recognizable and famous poy
trick out there in the world and it's a
personal
favorite and fun fact I'm pretty sure
that I can teach you this poy trick in
only 30 minutes that's right 30 minutes
to learn one of the most recognizable
poy tricks ever let's give it a shot
Drex here from drexfactor po sharing
with you the love of pois spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
in today we are going to dive into the
three beat weave and you're going to
learn it real quick but before we dive
in I just want to give a quick shout out
to the Friends of the channel big thanks
to dark bunk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyrot teror light
toys spinballs and Ultra boy for helping
to make the videos on this channel
possible you can learn more about all
these awesome companies and the work
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non-business
friend of the channel Becca becklen
thank you so much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission all right
so the three beat weave as with many
things with POI there's probably a
little bit of jargon there that it would
help to decode so let's take a look
right quick and see we can understand
what's going on here POI weaves are a
classification of poy tricks that
involve switching the POI back and forth
across our bodies as one hand goes over
the other crucially this has to happen
in what we would refer to as wheel plane
that is a vertical plane in which the
poy are switching back and forth from
side to side across you and spinning on
either side like Wagon
Wheels and of course as we're moving
this weave back and forth across our
body each individual poy has three beats
that it performs in the course of the
move hence three beat weave awesome so
with that groundwork laid I have a
five-step process that I'm going to give
you that hopefully is going to break
down these weaves for you in only 30
minutes so let me set up my home studio
and let's jump into
that
Tada all right let's get down to
business oh I really need a haircut all
right so the key to the 3B weave is
understanding that what's really
happening here is that we're basically
winding and un winding our hands around
each other and the PO are basically just
following that path so with that in mind
I have a fep process in mind that I'm
going to take you through in order to
get these down starting with step one do
the twist all right so in order to get
down that twisting motion we're going to
have to get it down with our hands to
start with and one thing that's going to
be really important for you to realize
as you're doing this is that you're
going to kind of do this in such a way
that you're imagining that there's an
invisible wall directly in front of you
and your hands can't get any further
away from you than that wall when we
come to step two we're actually going to
experiment with a real wall but for
right now the wall is imaginary and
here's what we're going to do with it so
start off by Crossing up your arms and I
want you to go ahead and start with your
right hand on top and your left hand on
bottom like so now you're going to
uncross them so you're going to reach
your right hand up your left hand down
they're going to be on your Center Line
here and then reach them each out to
their individual sides so the right hand
is reaching out to the right the left
hand is reaching out to the left and
then you're going to start to recross
them so left hand reaches up right hand
reaches down and you're going to come to
a point where you have your left hand on
top and your right hand on bottom
crossed up now we're going to uncross
and recross we're going to bring the
left hand up and the right hand down
left hand goes out to the left right
hand goes out to the right right hand
goes up left hand goes down and then we
recross with the right hand on top so
you can think of it as we're going
around clockwise as far as we can until
we stop that is our hands won't let us
go any further and then we go around
counterclockwise as far as we can until
we stop so we swirl around clockwise we
swirl around counterclockwise we want to
go back and forth like this and we want
to do 10 reps like this so think it's
going to be going around clockwise and
then back counterclockwise is one rep
you want to be able to do 10 of those
and again you want to imagine that
there's this invisible wall in front of
you so your hands are not reaching very
far away from you as this is happening
yeah awesome uh let me go ahead and show
that to you uh from a few different
perspectives here
[Music]
oh
awesome so if you've got down those
twists fantastic work now we're going to
need to train your body on how to do one
of those twists on one side of it and
the other Twist on the other side I have
personally found that the most helpful
tool for doing this sort of thing is to
actually perform this exercise in a
hallway so we're going to have a little
bit of a change in venue as we head on
over to another spot in my apartment
here and I highly recommend you find a
hallway in your own place of domicile so
let's go check that out now check it out
friends welcome to the a mystery that is
well the the hallway leading to my
bathroom but we're gonna learn something
really important here step two Off the
Wall okay so here's where things are
goingon to get kind of weird because
what I really need to do here is I need
to retrain my body how it thinks about
twisting my hands in either direction
where before I was just twisting them
around in front of me now I need to
think that the clockwise twist is always
on my left side and the counterclockwise
twist is always on my right side that is
after I do the clockwise twist and bring
my left hand on top I'm going to turn my
whole body over to face the opposite
wall and twist my hands around
counterclockwise I'm going to turn back
to the wall on my left and twist my
hands around clockwise I'm going to turn
back to the wall on my right and turn my
hands around
counterclockwise like so we really need
to make sure that we are trained to do
these motions on walls that are opposite
from each other so that they're kind of
faced in opposition this is going to be
really really really important for when
we start doing this with our POI but for
this step right now all we're looking to
do is to go back and forth 10 times here
thinking clockwise facing the wall on
your left counterclockwise facing the
wall on your right clockwise facing the
wall on your left counterclockwise
facing the wall on your right and when
you can get 10 reps of that down you're
ready to move on to The Next Step so let
me show you that from a few different
angles
[Music]
[Applause]
awesome so if you got your 10 reps down
we're ready to move back to the studio
and not a moment too soon it is very
cramped in
here okay welcome back to the studio now
that you've got that twisting and
untwisting on either side of your body
down well now it is time to start
learning how to do that with the
POI step three a dash of poi awesome so
now that we're used to doing that thing
where we twist around clockwise on one
side of our body and we twist around
counterclockwise on the other side of
our body I need to reorient that inside
my home studio here so I'm going to
imagine that facing down the hallway is
now facing off to my stage right side
and that down stage is going to be the
side where I'm twisting my arms around
clockwise relative to me and that the
upstage side is where I'm twisting my
arms around counterclockwise relative to
me of course relative to the camera it
all looks counterclockwise but that is
just the fun of having different
perspectives and different positions of
observance of this stuff so now I need
to add my POI into these proceedings
here um I like to start off by having my
PO just a little bit shorter than normal
so I will wrap them around my hand once
in order to make sure that they're no
longer than about elbow length and uh
I'm going to start practicing just
trying to use my poise extensions of my
arms as they twist around in either
direction on either side of me here so
if I start off here on my downstage side
with my right hand on top my left hand
on bottom I'm going to go ahead and
twist them both around clockwise and let
them come to a rest and then I'm going
to turn to my upstage side twist them
around counterclockwise and bring him to
a rest again I'm going to turn down
stage bring him around clockwise I'm
going to turn upstage bring them around
counterclockwise I want to get real
comfortable doing this so I'm going to
get in say 10 reps like this going back
and forth between clockwise and
counterclockwise like this before I
think about letting out the poy to full
length and once I'm feeling pretty
comfortable twisting around my hands in
POI with the POI only at about half of
my arms length I'm going to let out the
POI to full length and get used to
twisting my arms and play around like
that then starting over here on my
downstage side with my right hand on top
I go around clockwise and then turn up
stage and twist them around
counterclockwise clockwise
counterclockwise
clockwise
counterclockwise like so so in order to
get down this stage you want to be able
to get in 10 reps with the POI at full
length twisting around clockwise and
then counterclockwise as you go back and
forth between each side of your body
here's what that's going to look like
from a bunch of different perspectives
[Music]
he
you if you wait
[Music]
for awesome if those po are making for
good extensions of your arms as they
twist back and forth now it is time to
add a Beat to this pattern and that will
actually set us up for being able to put
the whole thing together so let's check
that
out step number four don't drop a beat
okay so the first part of this step is
we're actually going to have to tweak
what we learned in the last step just a
little bit so you know how we were doing
that thing where on one side of our body
we're twisting our arms and POI around
clockwise and stopping and then turning
all the way to the other side and
twisting around counterclockwise and
stopping so what I'm going to need you
to do is rather than doing a complete
twist and stop and turn complete twist
stop and turn is that you're going to
turn just a little bit as you're
finishing the twist this is what this
looks like from the front here so with
my right hand on top as I swirl my PO
around clockwise boom I turn to face the
camera when my left hand arrives on top
I complete the turn I go around
counterclockwise and boom I turn to face
the camera with my right hand arrives on
top and there's a very very specific
reason we're doing this so when that new
hand arrives on top like so and we turn
our body with it what we're actually
going to do is we're going to try and
keep the POI spinning we've come from
this place where we've had our uh hands
and POI twisted around and what I want
you to try and do is try and keep that
momentum going with the POI that is it's
reached all the way over to the other
side of your body I want you to keep it
spinning what is going to feel like
forward to you so the idea here is we go
clockwise left hand keeps spinning
forward counterclockwise right hand
keeps spinning forward clockwise left
hand keeps spinning
forward counterclockwise right hand
keeps on spinning forward for right now
what I want you to do is I want you to
see if you can get in three reps uh that
is going one 2 3 and then twist 1 2 3
and then twist 1 2 3 and then twist do
that 10 times that is 10 times with uh
the right hand on top 10 times with the
left hand on top going back and forth
between each side here's what that's
going to look like from a bunch of
different perspectives
[Music]
awesome so I know this one feels kind of
weird but the good news is is that if it
even feels moderately comfortable well
then you're set up for our last step
which is going to pull all the pieces
together so let's jump in
step five putting it all together all
right so if you are at the point where
you can keep those three beads going as
you switch up which direction you're
twisting the good news is is that all
you need to do is get it to the point
where you only need to do a single beat
with that POI that is crossing over and
you've arrived at the three beat weave
so what I'd recommend here actually is
that you try first doing one two beats
with the right hand on top one two beats
with the left hand on top one two with
the right one two with the left make
sure you're still turning your body from
side to side as you're doing this I want
you to actually look at either side as
you're going around
counterclockwise and then back clockwise
like
so now when doing two beats starts to
feel comfortable I you should be able to
get in at least 10 reps of that then
your next move is to get in only one
beat as you switch sides
and guess what if you can do just the
one beat as you switch sides and then
automatically jump into uh doing the
twisting motion on that side so with my
right hand over I go around clockwise
left hand over I go around
counterclockwise going back and forth
like so guess what this is the 3B weave
you've arrived congratulations now as
you work to polish this over time you
can work to move your hands around a
little bit less and just let the PO do
the majority of the work um I personally
like still holding on to the capacity to
do these bigger circles with your hands
if for no other reason then having the
capacity to go back and forth between
doing these big circles on either side
and then doing small circles on either
side is a great way that you can kind of
play around with volume and the
audience's expectations of what's going
on it's kind of a performance thing but
for right now this is the Target right
here just going back and forth forth
between our counterclockwise and our
clockwise our counterclockwise and our
clockwise here's what that's going to
look like from a bunch of different
perspectives
[Music]
[Applause]
excellent friends I knew you could do it
one more quick word before we wrap
things up
here outstanding I hope that this was
helpful if it was please post video of
yourself doing that three weave to
social media and tag me I am drexfactor
on Instagram Facebook YouTube all of the
things it'll work no matter what
platform you're looking at and if now
that you've got your three beat weaves
down you're hungry to find out what else
you can do with them I've got you
covered with the flow Circle the flow
circle is a weekly exclusive lesson that
is available only to my patreon
supporters this month I'm focusing on
three beat weaves and specifically on
the performance potential of them the
first lesson is already up and it covers
how to explore volume three beat weaves
in future weeks we're also going to be
covering things like how to add and
subtract beats to each side and we're
going to finish off the month by
learning the basics of the isolated 3B
weave a huge challenge make sure to go
sign up for that now over at patreon.com
drexfactor poy what are some of the most
helpful tips that you found for getting
down 3B weaves leave me a comment and
let me know also please be sure to like
share and subscribe to help other people
find this video and of course to help my
channel grow
[Music]
this video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a huge shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you so much for
signing up to support my work my channel
and my mission and if you out there
watching are not current currently
supporter but you'd like to become one
you can do that by heading on over to
patreon and signing up at
running from beginner to Advanced I will
go ahead and link to that video down in
the description as well as up on screen
thanks so much for watching make sure to
get out and flow today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon take care now
peace